and we're live in three well hello
everybody I'm Jeremy boring God king of
the daily wire and as many of you know
if you were tuned in last Thursday to
the Michael Noel's show we've made some
changes here at the daily wire we want
to wish Michael the best he brought us a
lot of good content over the last years
and we all look forward to seeing where
he lands but when I go spend today's
show looking backward a lot of news to
get to so I guess this is it
I'm Jeremy boring and this is the Jeremy
boring show
[Music]
so obviously trying to save a little
money on those opening graphics we
promise to do better but let's get to
the news another 72 hours have gone by
and in Donald Trump's America that is a
lifetime plus Alexandria or Cascio
Cortes said some just crazy stuff first
though before the news we got to make a
little money honey so let's talk about
our pals over at movement watch's
movement really listen I consider myself
a watch guy I own quite a few very nice
watches but the movement watch I have to
say it just shocked me this is a great
project it tells time like a champ and
you
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
I do have to remind you you're gonna
have this weekend just remember we are
shooting the second season of another
Kingdom right now hello sweet little
ELISA triplets oh oh hello just one
second Benjamin I just need something
yeah well but what is it then
yeah anyway you know I can wait you sure
yeah thanks I'm Michael Knowles and this
is Michael Nolt show all right we're
back a lot to talk about today I feel
like I've been gone for a while but we
have made it we've made it to the 200th
episode so thank you to everybody who's
been listening and watching it feels
really good
nice still hanging around here in the
broom closet so much to talk about today
we it was a big weekend very big weekend
there was the unite the right rally that
I think like four people showed up at
but it was a great opportunity for the
left to become very violent and
threatened to murder the President and
for the mainstream media to be
hypocritical and for former White House
employees to be hypocritical and Donald
Trump has this amazing knack for forcing
his opponents to be honest he does this
with the Democrats admitting that
they're socialists he does this with
teachers admitting that they're
indoctrinating students he does it
people are just honest he he forces his
opponents to project when they accused
their opponents of the the lefty is the
anti Trump people what they accuse their
opponents of is what they're doing
themselves we'll go through that bit by
bit before we do that let's make a
little money honey huh let's keep this
show on the air let's keep the lights on
and we got to thank thrive market thrive
market is really really good you know
there was a time when I was basically
living in the gutter and I would just
you know as a I was a bachelors what I'm
talking about I was I would eat you know
whatever sludge was in my fridge now I
use thrive market go to thrive market
calm slash michael mi CH AE l it is
revolutionary it's the online
marketplace on a mission to make healthy
living easy and affordable for everyone
you can shop for thousands of the best
selling non-gmo and natural products
always at 25% but
to 50% below traditional retail prices I
loved it especially I love their olive
oil but they have so much stuff food
snacks vitamins supplements
personal care eco-friendly cleaning all
that look you're worth it don't keep
putting sludge into your body let thrive
market and make it easy for you more
than 70% of the thrive market catalog
cannot be found on Amazon it's the
largest retailer in the country that
sells exclusively non-gmo groceries
there they're really good let me give
you some free food to celebrate my 200th
episode users will get $20 off their
first three orders of $49 or more plus
free shipping most shoppers are gonna
spend more than that anyway there's so
much good stuff
do the math you spent forty nine bucks
thrive automatically gives you back 20
bucks so your total purchase becomes 30
you get this deal three times in a row
that's a lot of math more math than I
can handle get $60 worth of free organic
groceries thrive market calm slash
michael mi CH AE l it's instant $60 of
free groceries thrive market calm slash
Michael so much to get to today so let's
let's just begin a lot happened that
that unites the right rally happened in
Washington DC you remember this from
last year the unite to the right rally
that very few mainstream right-wingers
went to if any unite the right it
happened in Charlottesville that poor
girl got killed by a crazy guy in a car
and what this is showing for the media
and the left is the or moment right now
is the I know you are but what am i
moment the unite the right rally was
really a unite the left rally they're
trying to make it a unite the left rally
they want to use these boogeymen these
handful of wackos to unite the left
because the left is having a civil war
right now the left is at war with itself
so last year this unite the right rally
just if you didn't remember I know the
media put it wall-to-wall coverage it
was this small gathering run by a white
nationalists Jason Kessler Richard
Spencer was there as well and what the
left tried to do is smear conservatives
and Republicans as being part of these
white nationalist alt-right groups and
now this is ridiculous as I explained to
my Prague review video the alt in alt
right is alternative means an
alternative to American conservatism so
we have American conservatism we talk
about our rights which come from God we
talk about tradish
not only religious census but all of the
the rights and the culture that have
come out of that judeo-christian
morality all that have come out of
Western civilization the alternative
right rejects that and it basically goes
back to a tribal racialism to come it's
it's so ridiculous to compare the
alternative right or white nationalism
to conservatism I almost don't want to
do it but let's very quickly let's just
kick the mainstream media out here here
is a clip of Richard Spencer explaining
what he and his buddies think what does
Richard Spencer actually believe no
individual has a right outside of a
collective community you have rights not
eternally or given by God or by nature
wisdom to us oh you have them because
you're a part of this community
ultimately the state gives those rights
to you so the state is the source of
rights not the end of it it simply is
what would be your take on say Reagan I
do not think that he was a great
president was your favorite president
there is something about Jackson there's
something about pulk as well someone who
only served one term but I mean Jackson
and polkas you know about Democrats I
party I mean party is just the the
vessel that that one uses in Jackson's
the founder of the Democratic Party he
goes on and on here it was a great great
clip from dinesh d'souza he goes on to
say that he loves the Democratic
populism of the 1920s you know at the
resurgence of the Ku Klux Klan
so the comparisons between conservatives
and Republicans and these guys are
absurd nevertheless the Left keeps
trying to tie them all together what
this really was is a unites the Left
rally and the reason we know that is
virtually on the one-year anniversary
virtually nobody showed up from the the
right side of the OLT right or the white
nationalists virtually nobody in
Charlottesville virtually nobody in
Washington DC here is how the the New
York Times covered it even the New York
Times had to admit this quote but even
with the low turnout almost no one
walked away with the sense that the
nation's divisions were any closer to
healing listen even with the low turnout
and
Charlotte's ville very few if any right
wing people and a ton of antifreeze just
you know ready to smash the police they
said but our nation's divisions aren't
healed yet yeah they're not healed
because of the left virtually no all
right white nationalist there were none
of these people there are statistically
zero of these people in the country but
the left comes they start you know
threatening the police tour it's
screaming getting violent they say our
nation's wounds are far from healing no
you have a violent left you have a
mythic a violent right there was that
one awful example last year at the
Charlottesville protests other than that
you don't really see violence on the
right you see a ton of violence on the
left the New York Times goes on quote a
similar dynamic to the one in Washington
played out in Charlottesville on Sunday
where few if any four right
demonstrators could be found and where
the most palpable tensions developed
between left-wing protesters and the
police whose presence in the city was
heavy and some argued heavy-handed so
Charlottesville part two and didn't
wasn't white nationalists versus
communists Nazis versus communists it
was leftist versus the police and by the
way the the argument last year the
lefties were so angry is that the police
didn't do enough to protect people and
someone ended up getting killed so this
year the police came out in full force
they say we don't want the police in
full force what do you want what does
the left one the left once destruction
that's what they want they want to whine
and complain and try conservatives and
Trump supporters to these neo-nazi types
and it's so transparent they're so they
are so projecting the outside of the
White House went in this unites the
right rally there were there was Jason
Kessler the organizer of it and maybe a
couple dozen white nationalist types
maybe 20-some somehow it's reported
there were about 20 of them with police
protection they did their thing and
there were a zillion and Tifa protesters
these are some of the things that an
Tifa was saying outside of the White
House quote it takes a bullet to bash a
fash okay that's a little violent they
said a murder Trump murder Trump do him
like Gaddafi the Libyan dictator who
not did not have a happy end couple
years ago a few years ago another sign I
can't believe I have to protest Nazis in
2018 but you don't have to protest Nazis
in 2018 there are virtually no Nazis in
the country there are statistically zero
Nazis in the country there are under
police guard because they would have
been killed all of them you know if they
had been without protection and they're
all I mean look the left is promising
that right they're saying we're gonna
shoot these people it takes a bullet to
bash a fash you don't have to protest
Nazis it's very hard you know it's very
hard for the left right now because
everything is going so well the economy
foreign policy domestic affairs
everything is going so well so they have
to invent boogeymen they have to invent
these Nazis they say it's 2018 we have
to we have to protest Nazis no you don't
just let them have their little stupid
thing and nothing's gonna happen don't
there are 20 of these people in the
country
don't it's okay where does the threat
really lie where does the threat really
lie
is it a these Nazis these neo Nazis
where they can get 20 of them at their
national rally if that or does it lie in
actual threats to the country you know
last week this was covered up by the
mainstream media very few people covered
this there was a terrorist training
school that was discovered in New Mexico
Suraj eben hua Hodge was caught along
with some other adults training these
children keeping them in deplorable
conditions and training them for school
shootings to carry out jihad to carry
out terrorist attacks
now does that name sound familiar Suraj
eben WA Hodge probably not but if it
does that's because his father was a
co-conspirator in the 1993 World Trade
Center bombing where does the threat
really lie where does the threat really
lie from these fringe in the crazy
right-wing type season at white
nationalists there are five of them in
the country
where does it lie in Muslim terrorists
who have attacked our country many times
we just stopped to plot last week does
it line and Tifa
who is getting violent which is getting
violent which is threatening to murder
the president but beyond that is
actually roughing up journalists you
know it this is the attacks on the media
of the most transparent here how many
times have we heard Donald Trump is
attacking the press he's assaulting the
press Trump supporters are assaulting
the press the press is unsafe well look
back
the weekend at the union Unite the right
rally which was really unite the left
because the only people at these rallies
were left wingers look at that some
media were attacked there they weren't
attacked by the right here is some
footage from an NBC reporter
that wasn't a Nazi attacking the
reporter that wasn't a white nationalist
it wasn't any of those guys who was at
lefties it was an Tifa they were
attacking an NBC reporter named Cal
Perry so you saw that you can actually
see it in the clip right the camera goes
down clearly this guy takes a SWAT at
the reporter either to grab the camera
and knock the camera down hit the
reporter we're talking about physical
violence we're talking about physical
battery how did NBC report a physical
assault on its own reporter did they say
Antti fho attacks the media and to the
left attacks journalists no NBC nat
sunday Today reported quote and Tifa
heckled reporters heckled is that is
that what heckling is when you guys take
a swing at somebody it's right over rip
their gear at steal their possessions is
that heckling I don't know about that is
that at Bill DeBlasio the bolshevik
mayor of New York he threw a post
reporter away he got he got his
bodyguards to drag away a post reporter
for asking him a question that you don't
really see Donald Trump do that you
don't really see the Trump supporters do
that do you what when the left actually
attacks the media the media say that
that they were heckled when the right
heckles the media the media say that
they were attacked isn't that
unbelievable you remember this story
from last week Jim Acosta Ron Burgundy
Ron Burgundy of CNN is surrounded by
Trump supporters and their heckling him
they're not physically intimidating him
they're not punching him they're not
grabbing his camera or his microphone
they're just heckling him they're saying
CNN isn't very good you know CNN is fake
news whatever and he said this was an
attack were under physical threat just
roll the clip here here is Jim Acosta
discussing this it goes to the press so
it goes to some other things that just
make his base get into a frenzy and and
forget all the other stuff that's what
it is
it's a big shiny silver ball at the
detriment of a Free Press
that's a serious moment in a serious
place and Jim Acosta's life in my
opinion was in jeopardy that night there
was a safety issue
his life was in jeopardy Jim Acosta's
life was in jeopardy do we have the clip
of Jim Acosta discussing this event
himself well I see I mean honestly it
felt like we weren't in America anymore
I don't know how to put it any more
plainly than that Americans should not
be treating their fellow Americans in
this way but unfortunately what we've
seen and this has been building for some
time since the campaign I've been I've
been talking about this as an issue
since the campaign when the president
during the campaign referred to us as
the dishonest media the disgusting news
media Liars scum and thieves and so on
and then he rolled that right into the
Oval Office and started calling as fake
news and the enemy of the people
he is whipping these crowds up into a
frenzy to the point where they they
really want to come after us at what
point was Jim Acosta's life in jeopardy
was he were the were the mean signs
going to attack him we're the funny
jokes about him gonna attack him was he
going to drown in laughter was that what
was going to attack him of course he's
not his life was in jeopardy
whereas however on the other hand those
NBC reporters that were out there were
being physically attacked where their
lives in jeopardy I don't know but you
had thugs left-wing thugs wearing masks
carrying weapons
you had them attacking reporters
physically attacking reporters so why
don't why don't the media report on this
aren't that the only explanation is that
the media don't actually care they don't
actually think their lives are in
jeopardy
they don't actually worried about their
reporters being attacked they're pushing
a narrative they have there has been a
narrative that is predetermined before
the 2016 election that was predetermined
a long long time ago and they are going
to push for it which is that the right
is violent aggressive a threat to the
country a threat to our democratic
republic a threat to the constitutional
order and the left is the Cure the left
is what is going to save them now the
trouble is the reality doesn't work that
way you know what's the line about the
left they say who cares if it works in
practice does it work in theory
doesn't matter they're going to stick to
the script they're going to stick to the
narrative so this brings us to the Gavin
McGinnis of it all you might have seen
this over the weekend
Gavan McGinnis who has been on our show
I've been on his show a couple times he
was banned from Twitter
Gavin now Gavin founded the proud boys
which is this group of I think they call
themselves Western chauvinists and you
know they're there they want to be an
answer to an Tifa they say we're not
gonna let you beat up our guys on the
street and you know it's a bunch of
young guys they're pumping full of
testosterone and energy sure they
twitter decided to ban Gavin why did
they ban Gavin did he violate Twitter's
rules no he didn't there's no evidence
that he violated any of Twitter's rules
there's no tweet you can point to that
says this is in violation there's
certainly no recent tweet that you can
point to say this is why he got banned
from Twitter but this comes just after
last week when Jack Dorsey the head of
Twitter said we're not gonna ban Alex
Jones because Alex Jones hasn't violated
the rules okay you're not gonna ban Alex
Jones then why are you banning Gavin
they banned Gavin two days before the
unite the right rally because they find
the proud boys implicated and unite the
right last year some of the pradd boys
were enthusiastic about unite the right
now Gavin McGinnis for his part has
totally disavowed the alternative right
the white nationalists he hasn't said is
and say I'm a racist I'm a white
nationalist I support no he doesn't now
he's a provocateur he's a comedian but
he has said explicitly I am NOT a racist
and I don't I don't support white
supremacy or white nationalism they
booted him anyway they booted him anyway
this is what I told you would happen I
told you this would happen last week
when they were hitting Alex Jones and I
said we have to defend the shirtless
vitamin salesman I know conservatives
don't want to they find it is unsavory
it's uncouth to defend Alex Jones you
say Oh pish-posh I'm not like him I
don't think that the water is turning
the frogs gay I don't take my shirt off
frequently in public I you know I don't
try to sell people vitamins I don't want
to defend Alex Jones I say well it's
coming first for Alex Jones they go
first for Alex Jones because he's the
easiest to boot he's so easy nobody
wants to defend him on the right or the
left so they get rid of Jones and
YouTube and Facebook did that Twitter
didn't quite do it but then Jack Dorsey
is under so much pressure he must be
under so much insane pressure from the
left to censor people it just gave in on
Gavin McGinnis
so now Gavin McGinnis is getting banned
on social media
Gavin's a little harder to ban than Alex
Jones but they banned Alex Jones to
establish the principle that they're
gonna start censoring more mainstream
people you know Gavin McGinnis has been
on Fox News a zillion times Gavin
McGinnis co-founded vice media Vice
magazine Gavin is a comedian he's an
actor he's a provocateur you know he's
got his talk shows and everything this
is not some like fringe Nazi who's you
know out there marching for a white
ethno state he's a little bit more but
now he's not totally mainstream right
he's now he's still kind of punk rock
vice media right but they they
established the principle with Alex
Jones now they're gonna push it to Gavin
McGinnis and he Gavin sent out a
statement when they banned him they said
you know they're coming for you next
they're gonna go for but probably gonna
go for breitbart.com then they're gonna
go for the Daily Caller now no no Daily
Caller now you're getting way more
mainstream then they're gonna go for the
daily wire and I'm sure they're coming
for us
they've already on these big tech
companies censor to our show my show in
particular they've censor Drew's show
they've censored the ben shapiro show
and at various times they let us live
now but who knows they are just
establishing the principle because the
left is furious the left has their
narrative that the right is a threat to
the constitutional order the right is
violent we can point out that the left
is the is the group being violent until
we are blue in the face we can we can
shout that from the rooftops do we have
that this is what Gavin is known for
this is not some huge Nazi this is what
Gavin is probably best known for on the
Internet hey guys a lot of you out there
are scared of babies you don't know what
to do oh my god they're intimidating I'm
so scared I don't handle it they are
easy peas to handle I'm gonna show you
how okay there's a lot of different
moves you can do to kick a baby's ass
hold them under the arm up like this and
then slam
this is a very little known technique
for fighting babies they're one excuse
me they're one Achilles heel is we need
you think you've got what it takes you
think you can take your old man a lot of
the fear of babies is assuming that
their punches or their scratches or
their slaps hurt they don't actually
hurt watch this
does it hurt a lot of people in the kid
community think that tickling is not
fighting that's not true
[Music]
you scratch my uh you just got me
running the I you just scratched my
actual eyeball so yeah dealing with
babies has nothing to be afraid of just
keep their nails trim and you're good
that's it that's the violent Gavin ooh
begin as he is I mean look at that you
think I can't even beat a baby the baby
took him down that is it and look does
does Gavin is he provocative yes does he
go too far sometimes
sure does he has he had people on the
show who were genuinely bad people
absolutely yeah Gavin's whole shtick is
he's gonna provoke he's gonna be funny
he's gonna have sometimes bad people
come on sure is that worth censoring him
is that why we should censor him no the
clip that has actually been going around
Twitter to [ __ ] to prove that Gavin is
this evil guy and further further this
way of banning conservatives is this
clip in which he is talking to I think
Steve Mossberg and he says that violence
sometimes solves problems here is expect
on the heels of what happened to Milo
that something might be happening
because of what happened at UC Berkeley
we were told we were told that they were
going to exact as they had made Facebook
pages and Twitter and New York ante file
was coming to disrupt they made it very
clear that they were gonna kick my I
didn't know they were gonna be using
bear mace that was a surprise but NYU
had a back door we could have gone in
and I said no I'm not going in the back
door I'm not ashamed so all of us got
together we went through the front door
but then they only let me in so the guys
who is score to be there were left to
fight and luckily they're great fighters
so they fought back and two of them
ended up in jail but uh overall it was a
really fun night and I cannot recommend
violence enough it is a really effective
way to solve problems so he's getting in
trouble for this one has to remember
Gavin is a comedian he it when he goes
on TV I think in that clip right there
it says Gavin actor commentator comedian
he says things that are funny so what
you expect him to say as violence isn't
the answer but what he's saying is look
these lefties were fear
violent there you know I had to be
escorted in I had to go in so clearly
violence does do something it does solve
problems but this is to be provocative
this is out there just as far as Gavin's
point goes violence does solve some
problems right it did solved a couple
world wars you know it's all of you this
is not to recommend violence in civil
discourse this is not to recommend
violence on the domestic front or
anything like that but just just compare
these two cases I'll use these two cases
to show my point Gavin McGinnis who is a
provocateur comedian commentator
broadcaster make some jokes about
violence make some jokes about violence
on a TV show the vice chairman of the or
the deputy chairman of the Democratic
National Committee keith Ellison is
being accused of beating women Gavin
McGinnis wrestles his baby wrestles his
baby in a video and then the baby beaten
and he tickles the baby and then the
baby beats him the Vice deputy chair the
deputy chairman of the DNC keith Ellison
is accused of beating women by his
ex-girlfriend and by her son which one
is getting play in the media which guy
is getting kicked off Twitter keith
Ellison kicked off of Twitter no cuz he
didn't make a video wrestling a baby so
he doesn't get kicked oh no it's Gavin
gets kicked off Twitter keith Ellison
listen to these accusations look I get
it we're in an election cycle sometimes
there are false accusations that come
out this happens with some frequency so
I again it's not that you have to
believe these things but they're being
treated with no seriousness by the
mainstream media big tech isn't saying
they're gonna censor him the mainstream
media or not taking the seriously I'll
read the accusations for you that you
can decide what you think yourself this
is from the son of an ex-girlfriend of
keith Ellison quote my name is Austin
Monahan and I'm writing this letter on
behalf of me and my brother my brother
and I watched our mom come out of pure
hell after getting out of her
relationship with keith Ellison deputy
chairman of the DNC for several months
we knew something wasn't right and
couldn't figure it out when we asked our
mom if everything was okay she told us
she was dealing with some stress and
would be okay in the middle of 2017 I
was using my mom's computer trying to
download something and I clicked on a
file I found
over a hundred texts and Twitter
messages and video almost two minutes
long that showed Keith Allison dragging
my mama off the bed by her feet
screaming and calling her an effing lady
dog you fit you can fill that in and
telling her to get the F out of his
house the messages I found were mixed
with him constantly consistently telling
my mom he wanted her back he missed her
he knew he effed up and he we wished he
could do things different he would
victim shaming bully her and threatened
her if she went public I text him and
told him I know what you did to my mom
and a few other things I met up with my
mom that night and asked her what
happened she said nothing happened until
I told her I saw a video and hell of a
lot of messages saying something
different she finally talked my brother
and I were so angry and hurt for our mom
we were ready to go public but our mom
begged us not to and she along with
others convinced us it wasn't in our
mom's best interest so that's that's the
testimony from the kid he's using his
own name it it is using his mother's
name the mother are now is is making
these allegations - it seems and so at
least their names are on this I get it
it's before an election but the story
isn't logically impossible plenty of
women in abusive situations don't want
to talk about it perhaps the majority of
them don't want to talk about it want it
to go away they feel embarrassed they
feel some shame for it now this is
coming out at Keith Allison is a pretty
radical dude again that doesn't mean he
definitely did this but these are the
allegations that are coming out how are
the mainstream media reporting this the
deputy chairman of the Democratic
Committee accused of beating women the
LA Times this is this is I'll just run
down the list
LA Times Ellison denies abuse
allegations by the way this is like the
first time they're covering it I'm not
saying this is the third article about
this these are the headlines when you
google Ellison abuse LA Times Ellison
denies abuse allegations CBS Ellison
denies abuse allegations People magazine
Ellison denies abuse rape allegations
The Root Ellison denies Politico Ellison
denies HuffPo Ellison denies Washington
Post Ellison denies Vox Ellison denies
Daily Beast
Ellison denies Yahoo News Ellison denies
only NPR only National Public Radio
the headline the actual news headline
congressman accused of domestic abuse by
former girlfriend now it doesn't say
Democrat congressman I'm sure if it were
a Republican who would say Republican
congressman doesn't say that it doesn't
say deputy chairman of the Democratic
National Committee accused but at least
NPR says accused of this congressman has
been accused of domestic abuse all the
rest jump right into it they say he
denies these allegations
he's accused he denies it though that's
not the story the story isn't that he
denies of course he denies it the story
is that he was accused at all that there
were these allegations out there that a
woman has said that compare this doubt
they covered Roy Moore do you remember
why Moore that flawed candidate over
there in Alabama these we've been in
public politics for however many years
and right before that campaign there
these allegations that he hit on fifteen
year olds at the mall when he was thirty
or something like that and the
mainstream media descended they they
crucified this guy for it now there was
some evidence that that the the evidence
here had been doctored actually we knew
that there was that the evidence had
been doctored nevertheless he's a
pedophile he's of this he's a scumbag
he's of this or whatever keith ellison
deputy chairman of the DNC accused of
beating a woman accused by the woman
accused by her son he denies it he did
it it's not this isn't a story he denies
it if this is really vicious I mean this
is awful talk about a war on women
they're believing this guy instantly not
even a question not even a question
he might have beaten this woman the old
line in politics is that when you're
running a campaign you ask your opponent
when did you stop beating your wife
because there's no there's no good
answer that you can't say yo yesterday
or weaker this it just assumes guilt the
media are doing exactly the opposite
they're assuming innocence they're
assuming that this woman who's saying
that she was beaten by keith ellison
they're assuming that she's a liar
you're just assuming so what happened to
like you have to believe the women what
happened to there's no reason for women
to make up these stories what happened
to me to what happened to all of that
gone gone because they're going after a
democrat they're going after a high
ranking democrat and they're gonna
circle the wagons around him really
really vicious stuff and it just shows
the corruption of the mainstream media
before we go i think we have a little
more time before we have to go don't we
do we have to say goodbye to facebook
and youtube
we got okay we got a little bit more
time the I do want to cover Omarosa so
Omarosa you know she was the reality
star from The Apprentice she worked in
the Trump White House in the reality
star White House she is she's making
some serious allegations against Donald
Trump she's saying that he's a racist
he's a bigot he's of this she's pushing
her book called unhinged another example
of I know you are but what am i that's
what we should we should call today I
know you are but what am i this famously
crazy reality TV store is is putting out
a book called unhinged here are some of
her so she's made the allegations that
he's a racist in the past she said he's
not a racist
she then secretly recorded a chief of
staff John Kelly firing her in the
Situation Room how she got the tape who
knows but she was recording him in the
Situation Room here's the tape we got to
talk to you about leaving the White
House it's part of my attention over the
last few months but there's been some
pretty in my opinion significant
integrity ask you a couple questions
does the president is president aware
don't let's not go down the road this is
a non-negotiable discussion I don't want
to negotiate I just I've never talked I
had a chance to talk to you two don't
cover so that this is my departure I'd
like to have at least an opportunity
understand we can we can talk another
time this has to do with some pretty
serious file integrity violations so let
it go with that so the staff and
everyone on the staff works for me not
the president
so John Kelly says you're being fired
because you have no integrity and what
does she do she proves it exactly right
in the moment by the way not in
retrospect in the moment she is
recording the chief of staff to the
president in the Situation Room huge
violation of national security
huge violation of even just regular
decorum to to record your boss certainly
when your boss is the chief of staff to
the president United States you're in
the West Wing she proves them exactly
right that this should be the end of the
conversation she says I've got a secret
tape of John Kelly telling me that I
have no integrity yes we're correct yeah
okay and then
everything John Kelly says I'll believe
everything you say I won't believe we'll
we'll analyze some of her lack of
integrity and where this is going where
the left is focusing on it I got a thing
about it Facebook and YouTube thank you
so much to those who are on Daily wire
you helped keep my show on the air you
know you help keep the lights on and you
know I've never felt like we've had a
really close call with that over the
years but I mean we really appreciate
you anyway go to daily wired.com if
you're on facebook and youtube you'll
get me you'll get the end reclaim ensure
you get the Ben Shapiro show you get to
ask questions in the mailbag that's on
Thursday ask questions in the
conversation that's coming up and I'm
gonna be on it none of that matters this
is what you need you need the anti fat
boo because here's what here's what's
gonna keep happening as we get to the
midterms and Tifa is gonna show up
they're gonna be ready to bash the bash
with bullets and clubs and they're gonna
be ready and they're good get there in
there are community fascists they're
gonna they're so ready they're gonna and
what are they probably gonna hit each
other they're gonna start hitting the
media or something either way they're
gonna be a lot of Tears you're gonna
need the leftist years Templar otherwise
you're gonna drown go to daily wire.com
we'll be right back I'm gonna defend
Stephen Miller I'm going to attack
Omarosa and then I'm going to show you
my favorite baseball player in history
be right back
all right so you saw that obviously
there are integrity issues here but now
she's saying that she has a tape of
Donald Trump saying a racial slur and
you heard this you know we had Tom
Arnold Tom Arnold's doing this whole TV
show on Vice land about he has Trump
tapes what are the tapes of I don't know
but he has tapes of him being a racist
and saying slurs and all this and what's
funny by the way is in that interview
with Tom Arnold
he made this allegation and then he
later said it doesn't it's not a big
deal people use racial slurs sometimes
as they're joking or whatever and you
know let he who is without sin cast the
first stone
I said well you said this was the
biggest deal ever is is Trump some
vicious racist or not but by the
evidence he doesn't seem to have any
animus against black people the black
unemployment rate is at all-time low he
hasn't singled out individual races and
tried to oppress them or over regulate
them or you know go after them in any
way everybody is doing better in this
economy he talks about that all the time
Donald Trump says we all bleed the same
blood of patriots you know we're all all
in this together all for one and one for
all
and I'm Rosa was saying this not too
long ago she was saying Donald Trump is
not a racist certainly he is not a
racist I've known him for a long time
certainly he's not a racist now she's
trying to turn it around for her book
deal to sell her book she's saying yeah
I was wrong you should believe me now
she is without any credibility issues
without any integrity they're trying to
do this now because one for her because
she's a jilted ex-employee yeah we've
all heard this before but the left is
doing this now they're going after these
ephemeral things they're going after
these ethereal things they're going
after these can't quite grasp but
nothing really tangible because they
have nothing tangible to run on in
November the midterm elections are
coming up and their hands are empty
everything is going too well so they
you're gonna see this ramp up and ramp
up they're gonna censor more and more
conservatives and they're gonna start
really really personal attacks that's
what we're gonna get you're seeing the
censorship happen already I didn't think
it would happen this quickly but they're
going after Gavin who comes next
probably another
next is gonna be someone who's a little
less of a comedian but you know still
maybe a little bit of a comedian he's a
little too far right he's a little too
provocative then they'll go after him
then they'll start going after just
regular old mainstream pundits and
commentators that's that's the way this
is gonna go they're gonna ramp up all
the way through November that's gonna be
the censorship side and then these
personal attacks
there was a really vicious personal
attack I am shocked Politico would
publish this even Politico as you as
much of a rag as Politico is I'm shocked
even they would stoop to this level but
they're gonna keep ramping that up
you're gonna get this with Omarosa these
unhinged unhinged I know you are but
what am i it's gonna keep up until until
the midterms
now Stephen Miller speaking of that
attack on Stephen Miller there's an
article today in Politico headline made
Apple News I'm a Drudge Stephen Miller
is an immigration hypocrite I know
because I'm his uncle
talk about awkwardness around the
Thanksgiving table you know you go home
and sometimes it's a little awkward
families have different political points
of view this guy's writing a hit piece
about his own nephew absolutely
despicable the guy should be ashamed of
himself just on the principle of the
thing
but here's what he writes he goes quote
I've watched with dismay and increasing
horror as my nephew who is an educated
man and well aware of his heritage has
become the architect of immigration
policies that repudiate the very
foundation of our families life in this
country so what's the point the point is
that Stephen Miller's family came over
as immigrants and therefore he can never
advocate any limits on immigration to
the United States just more more
emigrate just as much as no open borders
knock down the walls no immigration law
because if you descend from immigrants
and you don't want open borders you're a
hypocrite that's what this piece is
saying which is one of the stupidest
arguments I mean you would think
Politico wouldn't publish the piece
because about tawdry and personal it is
but even beyond that it's such a stupid
argument right now in the United States
the the foreign-born population the
percentage of the population that is
foreign-born has tripled since the 1970s
as a raw number I think it's quadrupled
but it's tripled as a percentage of the
population since the 1970s
is there no limit to the percentage of
the u.s. population that should be
foreign-born look where we're at the
melting pot right we take in immigrants
it was a nation that was founded by
settlers and we had early immigrants
come in from the old world to the new if
it's not that America has never welcomed
immigrants or shouldn't welcome him rich
at all but is there no limit what is the
limit you know it assimilation is hard
the way that America works is when you
come over here you abandon your terrible
culture that you're fleeing and you come
into our culture and then you give like
a good life you know and you make money
and you're at prosperous and successful
when you contribute to the country there
is a limit to that if you if you just
have I don't know let's say it's 50/50
foreign-born to native-born population
or 70/30 foreign-born genitive born
population at a certain point there is
no culture to assimilate to anymore you
can it's under the best of circumstances
assimilation is very hard but we've been
good at it in the United States but you
can't keep that up forever and you've
you've got to take some care to
assimilate people now we have a left
that doesn't want assimilation doesn't
advocate for assimilation whatsoever
there is a limit to these things so I
would ask the author of this piece David
Glosser Stephen Miller's uncle okay if
you if you descend from immigrants
you're a hypocrite what limits do you
think are legitimate to place on
immigration what's the limit so the
percentage of the foreign-born
population now is has tripled since the
1970s its way up since the 40s 50s the
60s you know that period of American
dominance that period of assimilation
what limit what limit you place is there
no limit is it just open borders okay
because that is that is very ridiculous
it's it's saying that any change to
immigration regimes is hypocrisy but
advocating different immigration
policies at different times in history
that's not hypocrisy that's
acknowledging the politics changes that
the makeup of the country changes that
the makeup of our politics changes you
know it's not you you don't have the
same policy solutions now as you had in
the 1980s or the 1970s or the 1880s you
have to adapt them to changing times
here are some facts on immigration if we
were to give amnesty to the so-called
dreamers people who were brought to the
United States illegally under the age of
18 though now they could be 40 years old
but they were brought under the age of
18
Democrats say that that would give
amnesty to 1.8 million people in reality
the USA Today estimates that's more like
3.6 million people that's just the
dreamers no majority of Americans wants
that to happen not even Democrats not
that they don't the majority of
Democrats don't think that that should
be a priority we also know that Hispanic
illegal aliens and Hispanic illegal
immigrants which is what a lot of people
are talking about on the southern border
they identify with Democrats between
three and eight point two times as much
as they identify with Republicans
they're between three and eight point
two times it's likely to be to identify
Democrat as Republican this is a major
shift to our politics if we're talking
about legalizing millions and millions
and millions of these people giving them
amnesty giving them a path to
citizenship giving them a path to voting
that is a major shift I understand why
Democrats are gung-ho about that but
there is a legitimate concern that that
will change our politics dramatically we
also know that 76 percent of immigrant
led households are on some sort of
welfare program over two-thirds of them
this compares to 52% of the native-born
population that's a change look in the
before the 1940s we had relatively high
levels of immigration not quite as high
as today but comparable 1920s 1930s but
back then we didn't really have a
welfare state did we the welfare state
as we know it was built during the 1930s
in the 1940s and then later the 1960s so
if you have all of this immigration
that's fine but what happens when
they're accessing taxpayer subsidized
programs and huge numbers
disproportionate numbers do the
taxpayers not get some say in that do
they is it are they bigots or the
hypocrites are they racists for saying
hey we don't want to keep giving away
all of our money to all of these people
who are coming and not contributing to
the economy and not contributing to to
federal programs is that racist is that
bigoted of course not we also know that
in many areas illegal aliens or
forty-five percent more likely to be
gang members is it hypocritical is it
hypocritical and racist and bigoted for
for Americans to say we want to vet some
people we don't want to keep importing
gang members and criminals on mass it's
that of course not that's not
hypocritical and then the final
statistic 60 to 80 percent of
women who crossed the border illegally
or raped and sexually assaulted it's not
according to the right that's according
to left-wing sources fusion the
Huffington Post is that are you a
hypocrite if you don't want that to
happen if you want to disincentivize
that because mister Glosser stephen
miller's uncle he seems to advocate for
more of that so you want to incentivize
a condition where 60 to 80 percent of
women and girls are raped how do you
like it how do you like these personal
attacks how do you like that because i
think perhaps that the right should
start employing some of these attacks
real attacks using real numbers using
real facts against the lefties they try
to make their fact free emotional appeal
we should have a fact full emotional
appeal to point out their own hypocrisy
and the the moral idiocy of their point
of view before i go i know we're running
a little late i just have to play this
point for this is america my all-time
favorite baseball player now in history
care of the Little League World Series
here he is my name is Alfred Aaliyah at
home they call me Big Al and I hit
dingers I love that kid that kid is
America this clip went viral it's from
the Little League World Series and the
internet loves this kid why because this
kid is America we did that whole thing
about soccer you know during the World
Series I had we went over to Delhi wire
to our sister network and had our sports
correspondent come on the god-king
boring this is a real American sport you
got this kid goes up there totally
confident this is my name they call me
big al now if this were soccer it'd be
like they call me little they call me
eco-friendly al they call you they call
me recycling now they call me thin
quaffed al no not an America baby this
kid goes up they call me big al you know
why I'm big so that I can hit dinners I
hit dinners that just the sound of that
it's not like if it were a soccer right
you'd say like I'm I'm you know a
quaffed Al and I lightly kicked the ball
down the field and we don't ever score
because it but a kick it and then our
teammates kick it that would be soccer
but this is America he says I hit
dingers I use a bat and brute force and
violence against a fast pitched little
and then I knock it out of the park I
hit dingers baby and that's why I'm big
I'm not I'm not trying to be this sort
of scarce austere little low let's just
not hurt the trees or though there's no
baby I'm big bold I'm brash I'm America
just like baseball I do a real sport and
I hit dingers out of the park gotta love
it
good good on Big Al good on America
that's our show thanks for being with us
and letting us get to 200 and well we're
gonna have to check in with myself in
the future at some point see what the
300th episode holds they'd be really
interesting to see how great everything
is going by that time so maybe we'll
check in with him in the future
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt ship is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Jeshua Elvira the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you